foreign
we're here to look at a box that cbp's
National targeting Center targeted this
particular shipment the shipper is an
entity that's known to us their previous
offender for smuggled artifacts coming
into the United States
we're gonna see if there's any more
Contraband in this particular shipment
that's coming through
pain Stone beads
there's some golden artifacts on the
bottom
but I'm not going to pull it out here
just because we can't afford to lose any
of these small beads
we're going to go ahead and transport
this shipment down to the Diamond
District of Manhattan and we're going to
have a gold specialist take a look at
the gold and determine exactly what we
have
foreign
ature what exactly the artifact is we
suspect it might be Bactrian and origin
the back chain culture was an ancient
civilization that partially overlapped
what is now present-day Afghanistan and
Pakistan
geographically situated at the Nexus of
a major East-West trade route it's a
perfect blending of Greek and Southwest
Asian art
in 1978 and 79 archaeologists excavated
the tombs of six wealthy Bactrian
Traders
known as the Bactrian gold The
Collection became a prized part of
Afghanistan's cultural heritage
2021 following the collapse of the
Afghan government the treasurer
mysteriously went missing
anti-smuggling authorities around the
world have been on the lookout for it
ever since
foreign
[Music]
how many pieces are we testing there's a
lot of little pieces but if you can just
do a sampling that would probably be the
way to go okay
we do run into a lot of counterfeit
ancient artifacts that are meant to look
ancient they're selling them off as
ancient but they're they're modern made
so we just want to make sure that that
artifact is the genuine artifact
all right so we're going to start with
this piece yep okay this one seems to
have like a semi-precious Stone in it it
looks like a pot of a Maltese cross
it's interesting
I mean this was going back you're saying
a thousand two thousand years yeah
so this is a piece of rhodolite darn it
and that would have been indicative of
the time
but they look at too close to Precision
cut
now this doesn't look like it's real
[Music]